bro did you see that um we made the uh
fox news
last night i get home right i'm looking
at some different news sites
that front page of fox news was joe
rogan reading the tick tock
oh when we were reading the terms of uh
service yeah [ __ ] crazy right yeah
but it was the front it was the main
thing yeah the head article is joe rogan
reads the tick tock agreement right so
it's almost like
someone said like is joe the only person
who's reading the terms of service of
things in america and the rest of us are
just using [ __ ] like right out of the
box like not even paying attention to
what's going on that's what i felt like
a little bit i think a lot of people are
now with with things like tick tock
because there's been a lot of articles
written about it and a lot of people
calling for it to be banned
because it's basically chinese spyware
but if they get us then what would they
like so say we talked about it a little
bit the other day but say they get like
they infiltrate all the electronics that
get all the data and everything but then
how do they get us as people like how do
they get us into the cages well
i don't think it's as simple as get
people in the cages i think what they
want is intellectual property they want
to steal data and they want to like if
they have access to your computer and
say what if you're working on some
[ __ ] weapon system or what if you're
working on
something some communication system and
they have access to your computer they
can steal that data
from your computer because they have
access to it because you're using tick
tock so it's just about information yeah
one of the more disturbing things is
saying that they have access to
computers that aren't even being used
for tick tock
right like other computers saying that
which is just that's crazy it's so
insane that that would actually be
something that someone would allow they
they had a an engineer a software
engineer back engineered tick tock and
said it was the
most
in terms of like invasion of privacy it
was the most egregious example that
they'd ever found
so wouldn't do wouldn't there be some
some comp some structure or template in
american society or government or
hierarchy that would protect us from
that sort of thing why that's what i
understand sometimes why isn't there
like a
something that protects us from that
sort of thing or is it just our own
responsibilities
i don't know
what they can do now other than ban it
but i know they were talking about
bannon banning it for a while but then
there was some sort of a deal that was
made where the data was going to go from
the american version of tick tock was
going to go to america but it turns out
that it's not it's going straight to
china and then they get the version to
america see if that's correct see that's
something
right that's pretty good yeah
and we're going to keep using it it's
almost like because what like what if
they had they told women there's a
makeup that would steal your face right
like you put it on and it's going to put
your face in china yeah and then we
still use it right
i mean that just shows me the level of
addiction that we have to uh social
media yeah yeah i mean it's a it's an
addiction they have an office here tick
tock has an office in austin for people
that need help yeah you know i found
about that some lady was heckling at the
creek in the cave and she said like what
do you do she's like i work for
tick-tock
damn
how old was she she's in her 20s oh
that's all right dude tony ripped into
that lady the other night that lady was
nice all over
a table is very sad there was some
[ __ ] drunks last night man some rowdy
ass people for a tuesday yeah you
crushed man it was fun it was cool i
hadn't seen you performing along i mean
i hadn't seen a lot of people performing
a long time
yeah it's uh here it goes leaked audio
from 80 internal tick tock meetings show
that user data u.s user data has been
repeatedly accessed from china
i feel like with these tools there's
some back door to access user data in
almost all of them said an internal
auditor hired to help tick-tock close
off chinese access to sensitive
information like americans birthdays and
phone numbers
and if you look at the terms of service
it's a lot more than that yeah what they
have the ability to
access is a lot more than that that the
terms of service is nuts just reading
that any company that would try to sell
you on social media
and it's one thing to like say oh we're
going to target ads in your direction
we're kind of used to that like whatever
like with google and [ __ ] like i don't
mind if they send ads my way but that
what they're doing is nuts they have
access to your audio that means they
have access to your [ __ ] microphone
they're listening to you talk that's
scary yeah like if you're having a
conversation like we're going to do this
deal with china and what we're going to
sell them is this but how much [ __ ]
they have to listen to of just people
[ __ ] listening you know like talking
to an animal or [ __ ] you know like uh
recording like a recipe for a buddy or
something like how much [ __ ] are
they having to [ __ ] say like it's
almost sad if there's just like a you
know just a feel like a football field
of chinese people
just listening to americans like [ __ ]
and clear their throat and [ __ ] i think
most that stuff they're not interested
in they're interested in targeting
specific individuals like let's say
you're uh an executive at a big software
company okay and they know that your
kids are using tick tock and their kids
you're also using your computer well
they get access to your computer now
right this is what it seemed to me i
mean obviously i'm a a lot of ludite
luddite luddite when it comes to this
[ __ ] so i'm just explaining from what
i'm reading in terms of like what could
this could be interpreted as they they
have access to your keystrokes yeah
meaning like whatever you're typing
right you're typing to your wife like
i'm tired of your [ __ ] like whatever
you're typing they have access to that
but it's just crazy that all of them are
going to be in their sleep those people
that work there and then in the middle
of the night they just have some love
letter to some [ __ ] you know a couple
gay dudes or you know some [ __ ] you
know kid like cinnamon is you know like
dirty pictures to his buddies it's just
like they're going to be [ __ ] losing
their minds i don't think processing all
that i know what you're saying but i
don't think they would access that yeah
i think what they would do is use it
specifically to target individuals that
they think are working on
valuable information
stuff yeah or if someone was like doing
something that was the the chinese party
deemed bad for china
you know
maybe some chinese person over here was
like
selling chinese information to them they
could find out all kinds of stuff
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one